(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos entender por que os
imóveis vão a leilão.
Para a gente entender completamente esse raciocínio, é
necessário fazer uma divisão entre as duas modalidades
de leilão que existem, que são os leilões
judiciais e os leilões extrajudiciais.
Vamos começar pelos leilões judiciais.
Os leilões judiciais, como o próprio nome sugere,
são realizados pelo Poder Judiciário.
E qualquer Tribunal do Poder Judiciário pode realizar
esse tipo de leilão.
Pode ser um Tribunal de Justiça, um Tribunal
Trabalhista, um Tribunal Federal.
Dentro de um processo judicial, vai existir uma
condenação de alguém pagar uma quantia para outra
pessoa.
Nesse caso, a lei estabelece uma ordem de
preferência dos bens dessa pessoa que vão ser
utilizados para pagamento de suas dívidas.
Em primeiro lugar, nós temos o dinheiro em
espécie ou aplicado à instituição financeira.
Em segundo lugar, os títulos públicos.
Em terceiro lugar, os títulos e valores mobiliários
com cotação em mercado.
Em quarto lugar, os veículos.
Em quinto lugar, os imóveis.
E a lista ainda segue com a ordem
de preferência, tendo metais preciosos, obras de arte,
embarcações, aeronaves e mais alguns exemplos que a
lei dá.
Então, em primeiro lugar, vai tentar atingir dinheiro
que aquele devedor que foi condenado judicialmente a
pagar o valor para outra pessoa tenha.
Pode ser um dinheiro em espécie ou aplicado
à instituição financeira.
Caso ele não tenha dinheiro em espécie ou
aplicado à instituição financeira, passa para a segunda
preferência da lei, que são os títulos públicos.
Caso não exista, para a terceira preferência e
assim por diante.
Então, qualquer leilão judicial realizado de qualquer bem,
seja ele de um carro, de um imóvel,
de uma obra de arte, de uma embarcação,
todos eles têm a mesma finalidade, que é
trazer liquidez para que uma dívida possa ser
paga.
Então, aquele bem vai ser leiloado para que
aquele bem seja transformado em dinheiro e aí
quem tem direito a receber judicialmente algum valor
vai receber através desse dinheiro, que vai ser
o dinheiro que o arrematante vai pagar pelo
fruto de sua arrematação.
E existem os leilões extrajudiciais.
Os leilões extrajudiciais, eles não têm interferência prévia
do Poder Judiciário.
Eles podem ser realizados por alguns motivos, até
mesmo por uma vontade de um particular.
Então, vamos supor que você seja proprietário de
um imóvel e você quer vender o seu
imóvel, só que você tentou vender da forma
tradicional e não conseguiu.
E aí você achou vantajoso colocar o seu
imóvel em leilão porque poderia atrair mais visibilidade
para interessados em comprar aquele imóvel.
Então você, por sua própria vontade, pode botar
o seu imóvel em leilão.
E esse leilão seria um leilão extrajudicial, porque
não teve interferência prévia do Poder Judiciário.
Mas, os maiores casos de leilão extrajudicial que
existem são os leilões realizados por instituições financeiras
que realizam contratos de alienação fiduciária.
Esse contrato de alienação fiduciária é um contrato
onde, de um lado, vai existir um credor
fiduciário, de outro lado, um devedor fiduciante.
O credor é quem empresta dinheiro ao devedor.
E nesse contrato de alienação fiduciária, o devedor
vai dar uma garantia para aquele dinheiro que
ele está recebendo.
Uma garantia para que ele realize aquele pagamento.
No contrato de alienação fiduciária com bem imóvel,
essa garantia é um bem imóvel.
Então, o credor empresta o dinheiro ao devedor
e o devedor, como garantia, passa a propriedade
de um bem imóvel que ele tenha ao
credor.
E aquele bem imóvel vai ser a garantia
até que seja quitado o valor que o
credor emprestou ao devedor.
Esses são os maiores exemplos de leilão extrajudicial
e são esses casos que a gente vai
estudar especificamente aqui no curso.
Por quê?
Porque esses casos que têm regra específica em
lei.
A lei fala exatamente quais são os requisitos
que o credor deve cumprir para levar o
imóvel a leilão.
E aqui um adendo.
É obrigatório que o credor fiduciário, no momento
que ele não tem quitada a sua dívida,
ou seja, no momento que o devedor entra
em atraso com ele, que ele realize esse
leilão extrajudicial para alienar o bem e quitar
a dívida do devedor.
Então, esses vão ser os casos estudados aqui
no curso porque são os maiores números e
porque exatamente a lei estipula todo um procedimento
para que esse leilão seja realizado.
Caso seja um leilão de uma iniciativa particular
de algum proprietário que escolheu por sua livre
e espontânea vontade colocar o seu imóvel em
leilão, esse leilão não tem maiores regras.
Vai ser a regra acordada entre proprietário e
leiloeiro.
Então, o proprietário vai falar o que ele
espera daquele leilão e o leiloeiro vai colocar
essas regras que o próprio proprietário falou.
Mas no caso de contratos de alienação fiduciária,
não.
Essas regras são estabelecidas pela lei.
Esses leilões extrajudiciais de contratos de alienação fiduciária
são popularmente chamados de leilões dos bancos.
Mas aqui eu queria fazer uma ressalva.
Não são somente os bancos que realizam esses
contratos de alienação fiduciária.
É bem verdade que a maioria desses contratos
são feitos com bancos.
Na maioria dos casos, grandes bancos.
Mas nada impede que outra instituição realize essa
forma de empréstimo tendo como garantia um bem
imóvel.
Ao lado dos bancos, quem mais realiza esse
tipo de empréstimo, esse tipo de contratos de
alienação fiduciária são grandes construtoras.
Mas para facilitar aqui o entendimento, quando a
gente falar de leilões extrajudiciais, vamos colocar como
se o credor fosse sempre um banco.
Mas fique na sua mente que não necessariamente
pode ser um banco.
Qualquer outra instituição que realize esse contrato, que
é um contrato de alienação fiduciária.
O objetivo dessa aula não é adiantar o
estudo do leilão judicial e do leilão extrajudicial.
Porque a gente vai ter módulos inteiros para
estudar detalhadamente cada modalidade de leilão.
Mas eu já vou deixar aqui nessa aula
as principais diferenças entre as duas modalidades.
A primeira diferença é exatamente a ordem para
que o leilão seja realizado.
Se for um leilão judicial, essa ordem deve
partir do poder judiciário.
Quem vai determinar que aquele leilão aconteça é
o poder judiciário.
Se for um leilão extrajudicial, quem vai determinar
que o leilão aconteça é o próprio credor
fiduciário, na maioria dos casos, bancos e grandes
construtoras.
Então, desde que o banco ou essa grande
construtora que realizou esse contrato de alienação fiduciária
siga o que a lei fala, pode colocar
diretamente esse imóvel em leilão sem qualquer interferência
prévia do poder judiciário.
Então, não precisa da autorização do poder judiciário
para que um leilão extrajudicial seja realizado.
Basta que o credor fiduciário siga aquilo que
está na lei.
A segunda diferença das duas modalidades é sobre
a desocupação do imóvel.
No leilão judicial, a gente vai estudar especificamente
no módulo 3 que a desocupação do imóvel
arrematado em leilão é ordenada pelo mesmo juiz
que determinou que o imóvel fosse a leilão.
Então, o procedimento de desocupação é mais simples.
É o que a gente chama de simples
petição.
Por uma simples petição, o arrematante vai fazer
o requerimento para que o juiz determine a
desocupação do imóvel que ele arrematou em um
leilão judicial.
Quando a gente fala simples petição, é porque
não precisa de um processo inicial para que
aquilo seja feito.
Basta que o arrematante, dentro do próprio processo
que determinou que o imóvel fosse a leilão,
faça esse requerimento.
É um procedimento mais facilitado.
Já no leilão extrajudicial, como não existe um
processo judicial prévio, caso o arrematante não consiga
um acordo de desocupação do imóvel com quem
está ocupando o imóvel que ele arrematou, ele
vai precisar recorrer ao Poder Judiciário.
E como será feito isso?
Através de uma ação de emissão na posse.
Então, o arrematante vai entrar com essa ação
de emissão na posse e aí é um
processo do zero, vai começar ali naquele momento,
já que no leilão extrajudicial não precisa de
um processo judicial prévio, e o arrematante vai
pedir para que o juiz determine a ordem
de desocupação.
Vamos ter uma aula específica no módulo 2
só sobre essa ação de emissão na posse,
mas é importante que você saiba que a
primeira forma de desocupar um imóvel que você
arrematou em leilão extrajudicial é tentar um acordo
com o ocupante daquele imóvel.
E esse acordo, por mais que no primeiro
momento possa parecer estranho que a pessoa concorde,
ele é muito possível.
Em mais de 80% dos casos, é
possível realizar um acordo de desocupação de forma
completamente amigável, sem precisar recorrer ao Poder Judiciário.
E por que esse acordo é tão viável?
Porque o devedor fiduciante, quando ele realiza um
contrato de alienação fiduciária e ele entrega um
imóvel seu como garantia para o pagamento de
uma dívida, ele tem a plena ciência de
que caso ele não pague aquela dívida, seu
imóvel vai ser colocado em leilão.
Então as pessoas falam popularmente que o banco
retomou o imóvel, mas na verdade o banco
não retomou, porque ele teve aquele imóvel dado
em garantia num contrato de alienação fiduciária.
E a gente vai estudar no módulo 2
que quando esse contrato existe, o devedor já
transfere a propriedade ao credor.
Então, tecnicamente falando, o credor não tem como
retomar algo que já era dele, porque o
próprio devedor transferiu a propriedade para o credor.
Mas é assim que as pessoas falam e
é assim que você pode saber que aquela
pessoa tem plena ciência de que se ela
não pagar aquele valor daquele contrato de alienação
fiduciária, ela vai ficar sem o imóvel.
Então ela sabe que o imóvel está sendo
em leilão, ela vai ser notificada que o
imóvel está em leilão e assim é possível
que você ofereça um acordo e que aquela
pessoa aceite.
A gente vai estudar no módulo 2 especificamente
formas de você realizar esse acordo.
Mas aqui nessa primeira aula é só para
adiantar a diferença da desocupação que acontece no
leilão judicial e no leilão extrajudicial.
A terceira diferença é a possibilidade de parcelamento.
Também vamos estudar especificamente dentro de cada módulo,
mas vou adiantar que a regra geral de
parcelamento de um leilão judicial é que seja
possível parcelar em até 30 vezes com no
mínimo 25% de entrada.
Essa é a regra geral porque existem exceções.
E as exceções aqui nesse caso ficam com
os leilões trabalhistas e os leilões que de
um lado tem como credor a União Federal.
Mas vamos estudar especificamente no módulo 3.
Fica aqui com a regra que é parcelamento
em até 30 vezes com entrada de no
mínimo 25% do valor da arrematação.
Já no leilão extrajudicial, essa regra é bem
mais flexível.
Vai depender de cada credor fiduciário que está
levando o imóvel a leilão.
Cada um vai estabelecer o que pode e
o que não pode naquele determinado leilão, naquele
determinado imóvel.
Então a gente vai passar por editais de
leilão em que o credor colocou que não
é possível nenhuma forma de parcelamento até editais
de leilão que o credor fiduciário estipulou que
é possível um financiamento em até 420 vezes.
Então essa regra é bem mais flexível, vai
ter que analisar em cada leilão o que
aquele credor fiduciário colocou como possibilidade de parcelamento
ou financiamento daquele determinado imóvel.
Essas são as três principais diferenças das duas
modalidades de leilão.
Vamos estudar cada uma dessas particularidades mais a
fundo no módulo 2, especificamente para os leilões
extrajudiciais e no módulo 3, especificamente para os
leilões judiciais.